sebastien for three years since beacon
happened you've been searching for
answers searching for me you didn't find
what you're looking for because they
didn't want you to but I'm here now and
I have the answers you're seeking
although I'm not sure you want to hear
them Mobius knows you've been following
us you think you have an understanding
of how powerful they are they're
everywhere
they've been watching me for a long time
there never was a rookie detective Julie
Kidman you know that now I was working
for them the whole time you took me
under your wing trained me trusted me
and in return I betrayed you I'm sorry
but you just don't say no to them Mobius
needs you now and if you accept our
offer you'll get something in return
this isn't going to be easy but long
before we met
you lost her daughter Lilly I know
you'll find this hard to believe but
she's still alive we staged her death we
used her mind to create another stem
system and now she's trapped inside it
Lilly needs you this is your chance to
save her to get back what you lost
but in order to do that you're gonna
need to go back into step again
[Music]
you